Cornelius camp looks empty the Syrian
refugees living here have been forced to
stay in these makeshift tents but the
plastic tarpaulin offers little respite
from the snow rain and strong winds with
very few possessions children aren't
even wearing socks and some of the
refugees have resorted to burning
nappies to keep warm they can't afford
fuel and wood the Lebanese government
won't allow them to build solid
structures sending a clear message
they're only to stay in Lebanon
temporarily a new repatriation Clause
demanding to space people return to safe
areas is expected to be voted in this
week as part of the government's policy
statement some of the Syrian refugees
that we've been speaking to have told us
that they would actually prefer to die
then live in these horrific conditions
it's a bitter winter things are getting
harder and tougher by the day for them
and Lebanon especially is going through
an economic crisis which has affected
the Lebanese as much as it has affected
Syrian refugees in another camp further
down the road a woman asked the seller
if she can buy eggs and pay at a later
date she says she has no money there are
nearly 1 million registered Syrian
refugees in Lebanon three-quarters of
them live below the poverty line on
around $3 a day since protests started
in October of the economic crisis
inflation rates have gone up across the
country and they're struggling to buy
basics people were kind enough to give
me clothes a blanket and fuel to keep me
warm other than that I have nothing just
under half of the Syrian refugees are
relying on cash assistance from aid
agencies but the financial downturn has
meant restrictions on bank withdrawals
so funds aren't always available making
it more difficult for some to cash their
monthly allowance mafida in Hamid's from
Raqqa fled the Syrian war six years ago
when our husband and two of his sons
were killed
she lives here with her family but it's
been difficult even though they're safe
for now and I'm taking care of my
orphaned grandchildren and a little fuel
we have to keep us warm is running out
the weather is cold I can barely cover
their expenses on Saturday President
Michelle Allen said international
assistance is needed in exchange for the
billions of dollars it has spent on
giving Syrians refuge and there's rising
hostility towards refugees here they're
often blamed for making Lebanon's
economic crisis worse all this making
their suffering increase by the day
Sahra Haider al Jazeera the Cavalli